>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Courtney Dell: As a
mom of three young kids,
we love Doreen Cronin
and Betsy Lewin's books.
They're a staple in
our house and have been
since before we actually
had children.
Doreen Cronin is a lawyer turned
full-time children's book author,
and Betsy Lewin got her start in
illustration and greeting cards.
Together, they've collaborated
on a number of projects all
with witty themes and
beautiful illustrations,
and their most recent collaboration
is "Click, Clack, Surprise"
and with that, I'll
turn it over to them.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Betsy Lewin: Good morning.
>> Doreen Cronin: Thank you all
for coming out this morning.
Betsy and I are excited to be here.
Betsy and I have been working
together for over 15 years
so we have been together
for a long, long time.
We've done quite a
few books together.
Let me see if they come.
There we go.
So, we like to visit
a lot of schools.
We like to go out on book tour.
We like to come to conventions
and mostly read to the kids.
That's the best part.
Writing is great.
I'm sure illustrating
is great but reading
with kids is the absolute best part.
A lot of the books that we
do like "Click Clack Moo"
"Click Clack Peep"
"Click Clack Boo."
We like to put a lot
of sounds in there.
There's movement in there.
So, kids, if you're out there
and you want to make sounds,
then make some sounds, and if you
want to get up and you want to move,
you know, be respectful of your
space but you don't have to be quiet
and sit perfectly when
you read, okay?
When you read, you can be animated
and join in and say what you need
to say and move your body
the way you need to move it.
So, if you want to do
that today [inaudible].
>> Betsy Lewin: If anybody
wants to come up front,
if any of you kids want to come
up front, come right ahead.
>> Doreen Cronin: All right.
Let's see what we've got up here.
Here we go.
The "Click Clack Moo" was the first.
Have you guys seen
"Click Clack Moo?"
You kids know "Click Clack Moo?"
Okay. Click Clack Moo is older than
almost every child in this room.
Click Clack Moo would be
in high school right now
if Click Clack Moo was a child.
So, this one -- and Click Clack
Peep, we had a little baby duck.
Come on guys.
Do you want to sit?
You want to sit on the floor?
Do you all feel comfortable
with that?
You guys do that then, okay?
>> Betsy Lewin: That's it.
>> Doreen Cronin: Now you can see.
So baby duck came along
in Click Clack Peep
and he kept everybody awake --
or she kept everybody awake
for a really long time
like most new babies do
and that's their right;
and then we flashed forward a
little bit and it's her birthday.
So, let's see how that
turns out for everybody.
There we go.
Some birthday balloons
with some mice hanging out.
All right, you all ready?
>> Yes.
>> Doreen Cronin: All right.
It is a very big day on the farm.
A cake is baking.
Streamers are streaming.
Mice are floating past the window.
>> Betsy Lewin: The
invitations have been delivered.
You are invited to Little Duck's
birthday party under the maple tree.
Cake, games, prizes, pin the
tail on the donkey canceled
by donkey, duck-duck goose.
Canceled by goose.
Steal the bacon.
Canceled by anonymous request.
I wonder who that could be.
>> It's a pig.
>> Betsy Lewin: That's right.
Good. Good.
Good.
>> Doreen Cronin: Everybody wants
to look their best for
Little Duck's party.
Duck takes a long hot bubble
bath to look his best.
He rub-a-dubs, rub-a-dubs,
rub-a-dubs clean and he walks
on over to the maple tree.
>> Betsy Lewin: Little Duck
watches and then he rub-a-dubs too.
>> Doreen Cronin: The sheep
need a trim to look their best.
They snippety clip, snippety
clip, snippety clip clean
and then they walk on
over to the maple tree.
That's as close as I'll
ever get to singing, okay?
>> Betsy Lewin: [inaudible].
Little Duck watches and
then snippety-clips too.
Don't do it.
I'm sure half of you
have already done that.
My kids have done that.
>> Doreen Cronin: The cat
wants to look her best.
She slirp-a-lurps,
slirp-a-lurps, slirp-a-lurps clean
and then she walks on
over to the maple tree.
>> Betsy Lewin: Little Duck
watches and then slirp-a-slirps too.
>> Doreen Cronin: Whoops.
Sorry guys.
The chickens take a dust
bath to look their best.
They shimmy shake, shimmy
shake, shimmy shake clean
and then what do they do?
They walk on over to the maple tree.
>> Betsy Lewin: Little Duck
watches and then shimmy shakes too.
>> Doreen Cronin: He's
looking good, right?
>> Betsy Lewin: She's
looking good rather.
>> Doreen Cronin: The pigs need
a mud bath to feel their best.
So they squish and squash and
squish and squash and squish
and squash clean and then they
walk on over to the maple tree.
This is my favorite.
>> Betsy Lewin: Little Duck watches
and then squishes and squashes too.
>> Doreen Cronin: The cows
like themselves exactly
the way that they are.
No rub a dubbing, no snippety
clipping, no slirp a lurping,
no shimmy shaking, and
no squish and squashing.
And then they walk on
over to the maple tree.
>> Betsy Lewin: Farmer
Brown frosts the cake.
He lights the candles, puts on
his best hat, and then walks
on over to the maple tree.
>> Doreen Cronin: Good.
And then they sing, you guys
can start singing, okay?
>> Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to -- eew.
A birthday surprise for
everyone under the maple tree.
>> Doreen Cronin: But still --
>> Betsy Lewin: [inaudible]
portrait.
>> Doreen Cronin: --
they have a great time
and it's still a birthday,
and I promise you she is not
the first little kid to show
up at a birthday party not
looking her best, right?
You guys did a great job.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Now Betsy has been
illustrating for a long time.
Am I doing that?
No. So, Betsy would like to do
some drawings for you today.
Now Betsy, is there anything
that you don't want to draw
that you draw a lot that
maybe you don't want to draw?
>> Betsy Lewin: Well, you all
know I can draw farm animals.
So how about giving me an animal
that you won't find
on the farm to draw?
>> Doreen Cronin: Yes.
That's a good idea.
Let's think.
Betsy's going to go to the easel.
You guys think for a minute, raise
your hands if you've got an animal
that doesn't live on a farm
that Betsy can do for you.
Go ahead sweetheart.
What do you want to see?
>> A bear.
>> Doreen Cronin: A bear.
>> Betsy Lewin: Okay.
What kind of bear?
Do you want a polar
bear, a brown bear?
Do you want a polar bear?
>> Doreen Cronin: Grizzly bear.
>> Betsy Lewin: Polar bear.
>> Doreen Cronin: Oh, cool.
>> Betsy Lewin: Okay.
One polar bear coming up.
>> Doreen Cronin: Now Betsy
does the backhand so fast.
You guys like to draw too?
Raise your hand if you draw.
Do you guys draw?
You guys are artists?
Beautiful.
A lot of artists in the room.
>> Betsy Lewin: Now where
do polar bears live?
>> In the arctic.
>> Betsy Lewin: They live
up north, don't they?
Okay.
>> Doreen Cronin: They
live at the north pole.
>> Betsy Lewin: So, we're
going to put this polar bear
on a cake of ice in the water.
Can anybody tell me an
animal that doesn't want
to be seen by this polar bear?
A seal? You're absolutely right.
He's just going to stay under the
water and stay away from that bear.
>> Doreen Cronin: That's right.
Unless he does jump in the
water and see that seal,
and what is the seal going to do?
>> Swim away.
>> Betsy Lewin: Swim away.
>> Doreen Cronin: Swim
away as fast as he can.
>> Betsy Lewin: Good.
Good thinking.
>> Doreen Cronin: Good job.
>> Betsy Lewin: Okay,
let's do another animal.
Let's see.
>> Doreen Cronin: One more and
then we'll have some questions.
Yes, pumpkin.
Go ahead.
>> A tiger.
>> Betsy Lewin: Oh, a tiger.
All right.
Big tiger.
So, here's our tiger.
>> Doreen Cronin: I think so.
>> Betsy Lewin: Okay.
Now this tiger is on the prowl.
He is looking for some prey.
Boy, we got a lot of animals
that can eat you going on here.
All right, we got to give
him some stripes, right?
Tigers have stripes.
Let's give this guy some
stripes and whiskers.
All cats have whiskers.
Okay. Some more stripes.
A strippy tail.
Now, if you want to make a
drawing look like it's moving,
you got to give it motion lines.
So, let's give this
tiger a waving tail.
See how it moves all of a sudden?
And what does the tiger say?
Growl. Okay.
Shall we do one more drawing?
>> Doreen Cronin: We're
going to do one more drawing
and then we're going to see if
you guys have any questions, okay?
So, if you have a question
in your head,
keep it there for just one more
minute and then we're going to see
if you guys have any questions
for Betsy about drawing,
about illustrating, or for me
about writing, about books.
Okay. Let's see.
Betsy, do you want to pick?
>> Betsy Lewin: No, you pick.
>> Doreen Cronin: You
want me to pick?
>> Betsy Lewin: You're the picker.
>> Doreen Cronin: Okay.
I did boy, girl, boy,
girl, boy girl.
Yes, honey?
A lion?
>> Betsy Lewin: A lion?
Okay.
>> Doreen Cronin: Excellent.
>> Betsy Lewin: Okay.
Now this is going to be a little
drawing lesson for you too.
So, first of all, lions have
big furry manes, don't they?
Big fuzzy manes like that.
Now we're going to give this guy --
first of all, let's
give him some ears.
Then we're going to
give him a big nose
and a mouth and a chin and whiskers.
Now, here's a little game for
you to play when you get home.
You know, when you look
at a person's face,
you can tell pretty much how they're
feeling by looking at their eyes.
Your eyes are the most
expressive part of your face.
So, I'm going to give you three
possibilities for this lion.
You have to choose.
Now, you know those little --
they're called pupils in the middle
of the whites of your eyes and
they can be brown or green or blue.
Now, if you want your lion
to look happy you want
to give him bouncy
eyebrows like that.
If you want him to look sad,
you slant them down this way.
Almost like the roof of a house
that doesn't quite meet at the top.
And if you want him to
look angry, really angry,
then you slant them
down the other way.
Now, it's your lion so you tell
me how you want him to look.
A show of hands, who
wants a happy tiger?
All right.
Who wants a sad tiger?
Oh, who wants an angry lion?
Lion. Why am I saying tiger?
Tiger [inaudible].
I think the angry tiger --
>> Doreen Cronin: Angry.
[ Crosstalk ]
>> Betsy Lewin: Angry lion.
All right.
We'll make this guy angry.
>> Doreen Cronin: I think
it makes him look scarier.
[ Background chatter ]
>> Betsy Lewin: Is that right?
No, oh well.
All right.
>> Doreen Cronin: Thank you Betsy.
That was awesome.
[ Applause ]
Okay. So, we've read together
and you've seen Betsy do
her work right there for you
in real time which is awesome.
Now, do you guys have
any questions for us?
Is there anything you want to
ask an illustrator or an author?
What do you guys want to know?
Yes, honey?
>> Can you draw a buffalo?
>> Doreen Cronin: I bet
Betsy can draw a buffalo.
>> Betsy Lewin: I can,
but you know what?
I think it's time -- I know a lot
of you have to have questions.
Don't you have questions
about writing or illustrating?
So, let's do that for
a little while.
How about this young lady in pink?
>> How long does it take
for you to make sketches?
>> Doreen Cronin: Well, when
you're sketching a book,
how long does that take?
>> Betsy Lewin: Two seconds,
but when I'm working on a book,
I start like that doing sketches
and then I make them more finished.
So, in order for me to really finish
a book it takes me between three
and six months depending on how many
characters, how much background,
how complicated the drawings are.
Three to six months.
>> Doreen Cronin: Okay.
Yes, hon?
>> How long does it
take [inaudible]?
>> Doreen Cronin: Oh.
How long does it take for the color?
So, you sketch the whole book first.
>> Betsy Lewin: I do the whole
book first in black and white.
You know, I use a brush and black
paint and then I add the color last.
And the color takes longer.
My drawings go very fast
because you see how fast I draw.
And I draw almost that fast
when I'm doing finishes
and then the color is
what takes the longest.
So, I hold that until last.
>> Doreen Cronin: Do you draw that
fast when you're doing the book?
Do you really?
>> Betsy Lewin: Yes.
Little Duck.
I'm just going to do this
just to show you how it goes.
We'll do one little duck and then --
>> Doreen Cronin: I
did not know that.
I did not know that
when she was sketching
that out it went that fast.
>> Betsy Lewin: This would
be a finish if I had a brush.
>> Doreen Cronin: Okay.
Hi.
>> Betsy Lewin: That
would be my finish.
>> Doreen Cronin: Wow.
And so, it's really the color then.
So, the color takes way more time.
>> Betsy Lewin: The
color takes more time.
>> Doreen Cronin: I
always pictured Betsy
for the last 20 years very
studiously drawing lines
and planning this out.
I didn't know she was
whipping this thing
out on her sketchpad that fast.
I think she actually
draws faster than I write.
It takes me a long,
long time to write.
Yes, sweetheart?
>> How many years have
you been drawing?
>> Doreen Cronin: How many
years have you been drawing?
>> Betsy Lewin: I've been drawing --
my mother said I was born
with a pencil in my hand.
I've been drawing -- the earliest
drawing that my mother has was
in one of her books, and she said I
was three years old when I drew it.
It's a picture of somebody peeking
out from behind a tree
which I suppose was me.
Who has any questions about writing?
Writing is fun too.
>> Doreen Cronin: You don't have to.
>> Betsy Lewin: You
got a question for her?
>> Doreen Cronin: Yes, honey?
>> How do you write your words?
>> Doreen Cronin: How
do we write the words?
A lot of times when I get ideas,
I don't get an idea
about a whole book.
I don't think, "Oh wait.
I have an idea about cows
and I'll find a typewriter
and then the hens will
get involved."
It just never works that way for me.
I will literally get a snippet --
like a little tiny piece of
something almost like a seed,
like a piece of a puzzle
because for Click Clack Moo,
the first thing I heard in
a million years would I come
up with the idea for typing cows.
What I heard in my head
it was Click Clack Moo.
Now, I literally heard that.
These are the kinds of things
that happen in my brain.
It's been happening in my
brain since I was little.
I've always wanted to write,
and I've always made stories,
and I've always kind of picked
out pieces of the day, sounds,
and people or parts of
conversation or something I've seen
and kind of filed it away.
I don't know where
the sound came from
but Click Clack Moo was not
a story first or an idea.
It was really just a sound.
And so then I had to
say myself, "Well,
what sounds like Click Clack Moo?
It's only one thing that
sounds like Click Clack Moo
and that's the type of cow.
So, it kind of came out of that.
Another day -- when we already
had the characters, for example,
I lost the book, Click
Clack Surprise,
it was let's give them
a birthday party.
Let's let them have a birthday
party but what would happen
with these animals
at a birthday party?
These animals are not --
they're not spending all day
in the barn giving milk, and
in the chicken coop
just laying eggs.
They have lives like we do.
They're out and they're doing
things and they're causing trouble
and they're really having
a good time and hanging
out with their friends and giving
each other birthday parties.
So, I have to take those
animals then and think
about what would happen with these
animals had a birthday party?
And then it just becomes
easy because I know
that that little duck
is a lot like big duck
and causes a lot of trouble.
I also have kids and
I know what they look
like when I don't watch them and if
I don't watch them for a morning,
I wouldn't be surprised if
they showed up covered in paint
and they're kind of a mess.
But still -
>> Betsy Lewin: And with a haircut.
>> Doreen Cronin -- yes, and my
kids have given each other haircuts
when I wasn't looking.
That happens too.
I do watch my kids but I do
occasionally not know what they're
doing 24/7.
So, then that idea just comes
to me that I just have to build
that out and I like sounds.
I like the sound of Click Clack Moo.
I like a shimmy shack.
I like a rub-a-dub.
I like sounds that when you're
reading the book you can remember
them really easily and then when you
read it again the next time you're
going to fill it in yourself so
then you become part of that book.
That book needs you in order
to really come to life.
That book -- these books,
these animals they want you
to come in and be at the party.
They want you to watch
them get ready
so you can do the same
sounds in the same motions.
So, I always try to put
that in there if I can.
Yes, sweetheart?
[ Inaudible comment ]
>> Doreen Cronin: Have
I ever written a novel?
I just finished Thursday
night at 12:33 a.m.,
I noticed because I've been
working on it for so long,
the final draft of my first novel.
It happens -- well, don't clap yet.
[ Laughter ]
You can let me know in a year or
two if actual clapping was deserved
but every time I write something
new, I started with picture books
and picture books kind
of came easy to me.
I don't know why.
I understand how to write them.
They're concise to say the least,
and there's a rhythm to them
that if you capture early enough,
it will carry through as you write.
And then I did some chapter books.
I did "The Trouble with Chickens."
I did "The Chicken Squad,"
and those are also really fun.
They're still just funny and you're
just throwing these little snarky
chickens together and just
listening to them and just writing
down what they're saying
and what they're doing
and the structure is a
little bit different.
And then you get to a novel and
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I just don't.
I don't know how to do this.
And the best way if you're sitting
down to write something new,
to write a new kind of book
or write at all is to read.
So, I've always been [inaudible].
I love reading.
Since I was a kid it was
my favorite thing to do
so when I really wanted -- I
got this idea for a novel --
I got this idea and I knew
it wasn't a picture book,
and I knew it wasn't a chapter book.
It's 300 pages which
to me is like 15 books.
That's a lot and if you do a
word count on a picture book
like this one or Click Clack
Moo, I think it has 130 words.
So, that novel was such a
huge learning process for me.
I've come a long way
from where I've started
because I have an incredible
editor and she's extremely generous
and very patient with
me, but I'm learning.
But, I'm learning.
So, I was so happy Thursday at
12:33 a.m. I sent it to my editor
when I emailed it to her.
So, even if it was
something I learned how to do
that I couldn't do before.
So, you all should know that
feeling when you learn something new
and you struggle with
it in the beginning
but then you get it at some point.
So, I'm sure I have
some more revising to do
but that was a big thing.
That was a big thing for me.
So, we'll see how it goes.
Yes, sweetheart?
Yes, babe?
>> What made you want
to write about a farm?
>> Doreen Cronin: What makes
me want to write about a farm?
That's also a good question.
I grew up on Long Island in
the suburbs near New York City.
I did not grow up on a farm.
Betsy --
>> Betsy Lewin: I grew up in a small
town in Pennsylvania surrounded
by farms so I'm very familiar
with farm animals even though
I didn't live on a farm.
>> Doreen Cronin: Yes.
I don't know why it was farms.
Again going back to the sounds
because that sound Click
Clack Moo involved a cow.
That's kind of where that
story took me was to a farm.
And then once I met these
characters and Betsy did them,
I wanted to spend more time there.
They were funny and I liked them
and I liked writing about them
and I loved seeing what Betsy
was going to do with them.
So, the farm itself, I
don't know why it's there
but that's where they wound up.
And "Chicken Squad" too.
I mean, they're not on a
farm but again it's chickens
and it's giant backyards
that I didn't have
and I certainly don't have
now but it's just something
about them that's really appealing.
Thank you sweetheart.
Do you have a question too?
>> I'm asking for my daughter.
>> Doreen Cronin: Sure.
>> You answered the question already
about that you were pretty young
when you started drawing but
she likes to draw and to write.
How old were you when
you started writing?
>> Doreen Cronin: When
I started writing.
When I was young, very young, I
was an extremely introverted child.
I talked at home with my brothers,
my sisters, and my friends
but you put me in a classroom
and I was extremely quiet.
I was just a very, very quiet kid.
Very shy kid.
But my first grade teacher,
quiet doesn't mean you
have nothing to say.
Quiet doesn't mean you have nothing
to add so she said to me, "Well,
why don't you start writing
things down because I want
to hear what you have to say,"
and she gave me extra homework.
I was six, and my first grade
teacher was giving me extra homework
to write.
And so, she saw something in
me that I was more comfortable
and probably still am to this
day writing than I am talking.
I'd rather write all day then
talk all day and she saw that.
And so, she just encouraged
me to keep writing and then
as it happened some of the stuff
that I was writing,
she felt was good.
Was saying that maybe I was a writer
and so she'd give me poems to write
and give me short stories to
write and all this extra stuff
that I had to do but I loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
And so, when I was six, I had a
teacher who I adored say to me,
"You are a writer," and
that was all it took.
And from that moment
on, I was just a writer.
You went on and did everything else
and go on to different teachers
and new grades and
different challenges
and learning new things
and then college.
I was a journalism major
because I was a writer.
And then I went to law
school a few years later
because lawyers read
a lot and write a lot.
So, I went to law school.
One of the reasons was
because I was a writer.
It just became part of my
identity and that was it.
And that started --
that was a teacher.
That's one teacher.
I've had incredible
teachers my whole life
but it was really Misses Cooper,
first grade who said,
"Hey, you could do this.
This is part of who
you are I think."
Yes, sweetheart.
[ Inaudible comment ]
>> Doreen Cronin: Of
writing which one honey?
>> Stories.
>> Doreen Cronin: How do
I get ideas for stories?
Just everywhere.
My family, my friends, my dog.
Talking to other people.
Looking at illustrations
that people do.
A lot of times, I can just open
up one of Betsy's books and look
at duck or look at the cows
and think, "What would they do?
What's going on in their minds,"
because they become almost real
to me and I feel like they want to
tell me a story and I'm just going
to write it down for them.
Okay, I think we have time
for one more question.
A short one.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, sweetheart?
>> If you were an author,
how would you [inaudible]?
>> Doreen Cronin: That's
a good question.
That's a good procedural question.
If you're an author and
you've written a book
but you need an illustrator,
now what do you do?
Because I don't illustrate.
That's not in my skillset
by any stretch.
So, when you write a story
then you're going to send it
to a publisher and then the
editor who's kind of the boss
of your book picks an illustrator.
>> Betsy Lewin: So, what happens
usually is that the editor is very,
very familiar with a
lot of illustrators work
and they're very good at matching
an illustrator with the author.
Some illustrators do rather serious
illustrations, very realistic.
The stories aren't funny and
that requires a certain kind
of illustration and the
editor knows just who to pick
and team them up with the writer.
Now, if the writer wants a
particular illustrator then they can
request that illustrator and
if they're available and want
to do the book, perfect match.
>> Doreen Cronin: Okay.
All right.
Thank you guys so much for
coming out this morning.
I hope you had a good time.
>> Betsy Lewin: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Doreen Cronin: And maybe
you learned something you guys
about writing and about illustrating
and then we'll be signing.
So, if you have something for us to
sign and you still have questions,
you just come on back
and you find us
and we'll take care of
it back there, okay?
Enjoy the rest of the day you guys.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.